a 20 million dollar effort to rid the
ocean of nearly two trillion pieces of
plastic is on hold after a major
breakdown the group behind the ocean
cleanup project says part of its 2,000
foot boom broke off and the system is
now being towed to Hawaii
the boom was trying to collect a massive
area of floating trash in the Pacific
that's twice the size of Texas it's
known as the Great Pacific Garbage Patch
Carter Evans spoke with the young
inventor behind the ambitious plan
nearly four months after setting sail
from San Francisco it appears the ocean
may have been too much for the device
designed to clean it 24-year old Dutch
inventor Boyan slat says the system
consisting of a massive pipe and
underwater skirt is now being towed back
to port after the crew discovered a
nearly 60 foot section of the boom broke
off what we saw last week is what it's
likely caused by what's called fatigue
our system has been moving up and down
in big waves around one-and-a-half
million times and that's what's likely
cost this fraction it's designed for 20
years we first met slide in September
just before the launch are you sure it
will work
nope we'll see in the coming months
right the device was designed to use the
wind waves and water currents to skim
plastic off the surface and collect the
trash but by mid-december project
leaders noticed the system would
sometimes travel slower than the plastic
allowing the trash to float back into
the ocean slat says it managed to
collect about 4,500 pounds of plastic in
its initial run far from his goal of
about 2,200 pounds per week my hope now
is that after having several months of
experience and two failures that they
would step back and see is there a
better use for this device can we modify
the design and use it to capture
plastics before they enter the ocean
despite these setbacks do you think this
is still a viable system first of all I
think we are really quite close to to
making it work I don't think
have much choice this plastic doesn't go
away by itself slat says after repairs
the system should be back
skimming trash from the great Garbage
Patch later this year for CBS this
morning Carter Evans Los Angeles let's
hope that works yes I think everybody
would like to see it work